Alabama Senate Republican candidate Roy
Moore is hit with serious sex
allegations so is Louie CK and we'll
check the mailbag I'm Ben Shapiro this
is the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
so the sickness has not yet lifted from
me like Doc Holliday I'm gonna have to
be sent out to the desert to cough up
alone but before any of that happens we
all get to the news of the day I'm gonna
talk at length about Roy Moore how
seriously should we take these
allegations are they credible what
should write more do and why is it that
everyone always seems to jump to the
defense of a person so long as they are
on their political side we'll get to all
of that but first I want to say thank
you to our sponsors over at Birch gold
so you look at the economy right now
it's doing great thank god it's all
great the stock market is doing really
well the real estate market is booming
but we have seen this before and very
often it is followed every eight ten
years apparently by some sort of crash
and that's why you should at least be
hedging your bets with some precious
metals you should at least have some of
your portfolio in precious metals you
can do that with my friends over at
birchgold.com right now thanks to a
little-known IRS tax law you can even
move your IRA or eligible 401k into an
IRA backed by physical gold and silver
which is perfect for folks who want to
protect their retirements and they're
afraid of serious changes in the market
Birch gold group is a long-standing
track record of continued success and
thousands of satisfied clients
countless five-star reviews and an A+
rating from the Better Business Bureau
you get a comprehensive 16 page kit
showing how gold of the silver can
protect your savings and how you can
legally move again your IRA or 401k into
precious metals if you so choose to get
that no-cost no-obligation kit go to
birchgold.com slash Ben that is
birchgold.com slash frnd use the slash
ben's they know that we sent you okay so
the big breaking news over all of the
day yesterday and and most of the day
today is Roy Moore
the very controversial Alabama Senate
Republican nominee he is he was hit with
a series of allegations by The
Washington Post 30 sources have talked
to the Washington Post about Roy Moore's
alleged history of Oh news in his early
30s trying to go out with women who are
anywhere from 14 to 18 years old the
most serious allegation is brought by
one particular woman who was 14 years
old named Blake Hoffman and she alleged
his sexual assault by Roy Moore when he
was 32 and she was 14
the allegations themselves are sickening
there are some people today who are
trying to make light of the allegations
by saying well you know he's 32 and
she's 16 or 17 is that such a big deal I
am 33 years old okay
I'm exactly the age that Roy Moore was
when Roy Moore was apparently doing this
stuff the idea of even going anywhere
near a high school freshman is so
perverse and sickening and anyone who
ever tried to do that to my sister or my
daughter I would be very tempted to grab
my shotgun from my safe drive them to a
remote spot and take them out really if
someone were molesting if my 14 year old
sister that would be the proper solution
now the question is whether these
allegations are true or not but here's
what the Washington Post says and we owe
it to the people who have spoken on the
record by name to at least take the
allegation seriously and the reason I
say that is there's this tendency on
some people part of some people but on
both the right and the left to basically
let things go when it's when it's your
side right so Teddy Kennedy drives a car
off a bridge there's a woman in the back
she dies but Teddy Kennedy he's really
an important politician he's part of the
Kennedy family so we let it go Bill
Clinton he can molest the help doesn't
matter so long as Bill Clinton is for
abortion naina Burrell a of Time
magazine says that she would perform
oral sex on him as long as he keeps
abortion legal right we see this with
Donald Trump in the last election cycle
all these allegations of sexual assault
and sexual harassment hit and a lot of
people say well you know lesser of two
evils you still got a vote for him or at
least we still we at least have to voice
support for him now I'm not going to
equate voting for a candidate with
necessarily supporting everything that
the candidate is does it has done in the
past because there is more to it than
that but there is a moral question here
as to whether you are allowed to either
vote or support a candidate who does
these sorts of things and this is
something that I had serious problems
with during the election cycle the
lesser of two evils mentality
particularly in politics will lead to
the worsening of all of our politicians
because basically it allows you to get
away with anything my Teddy Kennedy can
murder someone and that's totally fine
so long as Teddy Kennedy votes the right
way Bill Clinton came unless the help
totally fine so long as you votes the
way the right way Donald Trump will be
the right way on abortion for the right
therefore who cares whether he was
saying that he could grab women by the
p-word and then there were allegations
of sexual assault by a number of women
some of whom were underage right and all
of this goes by the wayside I hate this
stuff I hate it
the reason I hate it is because in the
end the American people are going to
have to decide what kind of people we
are
are we the kinds of people who care so
much about the policy is a little about
the character of our politicians that we
are willing to elect the worst P
in America just to defeat the other side
or are we gonna have to get together and
collectively bargain together against
our own immorality because what we have
here is a basic classic prisoner's
dilemma I've talked about game theory on
the program before a president
prisoner's dilemma is essentially a
situation in which your dominant
strategy is to do the worst possible
thing so to elucidate what a prisoner's
dilemma is for purposes of this
discussion think of two guys it's the
movie LA Confidential starring Kevin
Spacey and in that movie they they
capture two suspects they put them in
separate rooms and then they tell each
suspect if you rat on the other guy then
we will let you off but if you do not
rat and the other guy wraps you out
you're gonna get the max sentence if you
bow trap both rat on each other then
you're going to get somewhere in the
Midway right you're gonna get instead of
a 10-year sentence you'll both get a
five-year sentence so the best solution
for these guys would be to not testify
to anything right the best solution
would be for them to keep their mouths
shut because then they'd be released the
second best solution for both of them is
if they is if they testified the other
guy did something wrong right so if they
both testify the other guy did something
wrong that's the best possible solution
because if you say the other guy did
something wrong you get out and the
other guy goes to jail well the problem
is unless you really really trust the
other guy you're both gonna cheat but
you're both gonna say the other guy did
something wrong you're gonna tell on
each other and you're both gonna go to
jail that's what's happening here with
regard to bad people who are politicians
right the right doesn't trust the left
rightly so we don't trust that the left
is gonna uphold any sort of moral
standard with regard to their candidates
we look at all of these politicians that
they've supported despite how disgusting
they are and we say well if you're not
gonna support if you're not gonna
withdraw support from politicians who do
disgusting things why should we why
should we hamper ourselves by handing
you an Alabama Senate seat by not
supporting somebody like Roy Moore this
is immoral logic because there's an
actual more the difference between a
normal prisoner's dilemma and this is
that there's an actual moral imperative
for people to come out against sexual
assault that does not exist in a normal
prisoner's dilemma situation but you can
see why everyone is falling into this
trap right and left the left looks at
the right
they say you supported Trump why
shouldn't we support Clinton the right
looks at the left it says you supported
Clinton why shouldn't we support Trump
each looks at the other and they say you
guys support bad guys why shouldn't we
support bad guys and so we
end up supporting bad guys we need to
have a bargain with one another as
Americans everyone needs to say I am NOT
going to support bad people now here are
the allegations about Roy Moore the easy
way out for people on the right has been
over the past 48 hours to basically say
well it's not been proven one of the
problems of sexual assault allegations
is it's very difficult to prove them
right particularly forty years after the
fact if you believed Juanita Broderick
but you don't believe Lake Hoffman you
need to ask yourself why does it have
something to do with politics or is
there something more credible about
Juanita Broderick than Mike Horstman I
don't think there really is I think that
lake orphan seems relatively credible
and again you know one of the questions
here is going to be does this fall apart
over time does the story fall apart over
time you know Roy Moore denies the
allegations but you have to judge for
yourself and I think that we all have to
be intellectually honest do you doubt
the story or do you doubt the story for
political purposes right you doubt that
the story is true or do you doubt it
because you want to vote for Roy Moore
because you want to support Roy Moore
here's the allegation on Thursday the
Washington Post dropped a bombshell
report on Alabama Senate Republican
nominee Roy Moore they allege he engaged
in a sexual assault of a 14 year old and
that he solicited multiple other
underage women some four decades ago so
according to Post report this is over a
Daily wire in 1979 more then thirty two
years old allegedly met a 14-year old
girl named Lake Hoffman outside a
courtroom he asked for her phone number
picked her up at her home took her to
his home where he quote took off her
shirt and pants and removed his clothes
he touched her over her bra and
Underpants she said and guided her hand
to touch him over his underwear after
that she asked him to take her home and
he complied okay now there's that would
be just one allegation but there are
multiple allegations of more
propositioning women who are very very
young three other women between the ages
of 16 and 18 say more proposition them
during that same period the post adds
that none of the women say that more
actually forced them into any sort of
relationship or sexual contact so it is
slightly different than this more most
egregious allegation according to the
post Wendy Miller says she was 14 and
working as a Santa's helper at the
Gadsden Mall when Moore first approached
her 16 when he asked her on dates which
her mother forbade Debbie Wesley Wesson
Gibson says she was 17 when Moore spoke
to her high school civics class and
asked her out on the first of several
dates that did not progress beyond
kissing Gloria fact are decent said she
was an eighteen-year-old cheerleader
when Moore began taking around dates
that included bottles of
mattias Rose a wine the legal drinking
age in Alabama was 19 the last one you
see the the Washington Post trying to
stretch a little bit you know a 32 year
old guy dating an 18 year old girl is
not my cup of tea but suggesting that
the real wrongdoing is that she drank ok
underage drinking is a thing in the
United States get the idea that 18
year-olds don't drink is just sewing in
any case you know approaching 14
year-olds for Nate's and 16 year-olds
for dates and 17 year-olds for dates
when you are 32 years old yuck yuck so
more denies the allegations Kaufman by
the way voted for President Trump in
she says she did not come out earlier on
this story because she has thrice
divorced and has children and was afraid
that her story would be doubted so a lot
of people on the right are saying this
looks like a coordinated hit there's one
month out from an election and Roy Moore
suddenly is being hit with these charges
it looks like an oppo dump right why are
all these women coming out now now what
the Post says is as soon as we started
talking and see these women separately
we went down to start reporting on this
race this is the post says in the
article we started reporting on the race
we're ignoring it cuz it wasn't that
important it's an Alabama Senate race
the Republican always wins but we decide
to go down and report on it and when we
did there are these rumors about Roy
Moore doing all these things we went and
we reached out to all of these women
they all spoke on the record they all
gave their names and they all told us
similar stories so that adds some
credibility to these particular
allegations so here's so so the question
becomes number one whether people should
support more and the second question
becomes whether more should be moved off
the ballot involuntarily it's very
difficult to get more removed from the
ballot if you do that you can't replace
him with anybody else there's a sore
loser law in Alabama that makes it
nearly impossible for the Alabama
Republican Party to replace him on the
ballot now you remember back at all the
way to 2002 the Democrats had a similar
problem with a senator named bob
torricelli bob the torturer Torricelli
he was involved in corruption and the
New Jersey Democrats sued to have him
removed from the ballot and replaced on
the ballot by someone else and the court
ruled that was okay which was a
violation of the law and a lot of
Republicans were very upset about it
well this is a similar sort of situation
so Roy Moore is denying all this here is
his statement he says today the judge
Roy Moore campaign for US Senate issued
a statement responding to yet another
baseless political attack by The
Washington Post a paper that is endorsed
judge Moore's opponent more campaign
chair bill Armistead released the
following statement on Thursday
afternoon quote judge Roy Moore has
enjoyed the most outlandish
any candidate in the modern political
arena but this story in today's
Washington Post alleging sexual
impropriety takes the cake
national liberal organizations know
their chosen candidates Doug Jones in a
death spiral and this is their
last-ditch Hail Mary's so he's relying
on the media bias charge again that
carries some weight right you do have to
say that the media bias charge carries
some weight when the media you know the
same Washington Post way back when I
believe it was actually Newsweek way
back when I was quashing Lewinsky stuff
but you know the Washington Post is
against Roy Moore but that's not changed
the the credibility of the accusers
right the accuser is our name again
since the Washington Post has already
endorsed the judges opponent and for
months they've engaged in a systematic
campaign to distort the truth about the
judges record and career and derail his
campaign in fact just two days ago the
foundation for moral law sense or
attractions a man to the post for the
false stories they wrote about the
judges work in compensation but
apparently there is no end to what the
post will allege that story by the way
is still out there the post has not
retracted that story that that story
says that Roy Moore took about two
hundred thousand dollars from the
foundation for moral law for doing very
little work indeed the statement
continues
the judge has been married to Kayla for
nearly thirty three years has four
children and five grandchildren he has
been a candidate and for hotly-contested
statewide political contest twice as a
gubernatorial candidate twice as a
candidate for chief justice has been a
three-time candidate for local office
has been a national figure in two
groundbreaking judicial fights of a
religious liberty and traditional
marriage after 40 years of public
service if any of these allegations were
true they would have been made public
long before now okay now that's not an
argument I particularly like the
argument that we would have known about
this earlier because we now know that
there are allegations that are surfacing
about a wide variety of public figures
that nobody knew earlier or if they did
they were rumored but never confirmed
right Harvey Weinstein was doing this
crap for 20 years and we're fighting
about it now Denny Hastert was the
Speaker of the House for the Republicans
for several years Denny Hastert turns
out was molesting high school boys right
so this idea that that it didn't come
out for decades therefore it must not be
true that's a little bit of weak T it's
a little bit of weak to you they say the
garbage is the very definition of thick
news an intentional defamation you know
the question is whether Roy Moore is
gonna actually file a lawsuit even if it
files a lawsuit no guarantee that the
lawsuit is is either going to succeed or
that approves that Roy Moore is innocent
of the charges you can file a lawsuit
and then later drop the lawsuit right
without being countersued presumably
president Trump has sounded off
according to the press secretary
she says that boy that Trump said quote
he believes if allegations are true he
will do the right thing and step aside
it's calling for more to step aside if
the allegations are true but that
statement if the allegations are true is
a pretty dicey one because again there's
no way for anyone to confirm whether the
allegations are true except based on
except based on the word of the person
who's talking about this so I know there
are a lot of people who are thinking
about you know why wouldn't these women
come forward earlier why did they keep
silent for so long and I think that it
is important to read some of the
accounts of women who didn't come
forward earlier I'm just trying to be
intellectually honest as I can be about
this because I don't know and you don't
know right I don't know whether it's
true and you don't know whether it's
true all we can do is go based on the
allegations that are made by four
different named women in the Washington
Post report and somewhat substantiative
by supposedly about 30 witnesses right
so people who are talked to at the time
I'm gonna get to why I think it's
important to read the accounts of women
who have kept silent for a long time
about people who molested them in just a
second but first I want to say thank you
to our sponsors over at the u.s. ECA so
you've heard me talking a lot about the
u.s. concealed-carry Association and
right now you get to go to their free
live training event Tuesday the 14th and
and it's all about what your do what you
should do if you are forced to defend
yourself in your home you'll get to ask
your questions live as personal defense
experts show what you can and cannot you
when you can and cannot use deadly force
in your house what happens after your
shoot you will be arrested and what you
should do training skills to keep those
skills sharp and you can make sure you
get all of this at their live training
events go to concealed-carry live.com to
secure your spot again you'll get the
concealed carry live.com you get all
that information plus you get three
chances to win a Glock 19 just for
registering they're giving away three
Glocks live during the training don't
miss out concealed carry live.com now to
get your three chances to win again
that's concealed-carry live.com
concealed carry live comm gets you great
information plus the three chances to
win a gun which is pretty cool okay so
there's what I think it's kind of a
heartbreaking account from Nancy French
Nancy French is uh the friendly with the
Daily wire she's the wife of David
French with whom I'm pretty good friends
and Nancy has ghostwritten for a wide
variety of right-wing public figures
ranging from David Clarke to to Sarah
Palin and and here is a here's what she
says she does I used to admire men like
Roy Moore
because I loved everything about church
the off-key acapella rendition of onward
Christian soldiers the typos in the
bulletin the ladies who smelled like
Aqua Net with little Rouge circles on
their cheeks and yes men like more who
said long prayers around the show this
changed one hot summer day when I needed
to ride home from Vacation Bible School
I was delighted when the preacher
volunteered to drop me off as we drove I
chatted incessantly happy to have him
all to myself without people trying to
get his attention in the church parking
lot well he got to my house I was
shocked that he walked me inside my dark
house even more surprised when he
lingered in conversation and
thunderstruck when he kissed me right on
the lips at 12 years old I swooned over
my good luck he picked me out of all the
girls of church but the relationship
especially after he moved on reset my
moral compass and fall the church
conversation about morality and sexual
purity was a lie what else was fake now
that the family of God felt incestuous I
rejected the church and myself didn't I
want the preachers attention didn't I
cause this when I careened from faith I
made a series of poor romantic decisions
that later almost cost me my life still
I couldn't very well criticize the
church because I was an utter emotional
mess on Thursday all of this came back
to me after I read one sentence in The
Washington Post the article was about
allegations that Alabama Senate
candidate Roy more sexually touched a
teenager when he was in his 30s a
sentence from Leigh Kaufmann who was 14
at the time jumped out at me quote I
felt responsible she said I swallow her
back tears as I read the rest I felt
like I had done something bad and I kind
of set the course for me doing other
things that were bad after her life
spiraled with drinking drugs boyfriends
she attempted suicide two years later in
fact she didn't come forward earlier
because she worried that her three
divorces in poor financial history would
make people doubt her story this is one
of the reasons why women don't come
forward sooner is because they do carry
guilt when there are situations like
this and sexual predators this is well
known whether or not Roy Moore is one is
still question you know but it is true
sexual predators tend to target girls
who are in a vulnerable state they tend
to target girls who they can shed shed
some sort of shadow on them their
credibility if something is push it come
to shove they'll build target girls who
are fragile emotionally and and seen as
unstable and then if the girl says
something they'll say that it was
fabricated and this is this very
well-known that this is something that
older male sexual predators will do okay
with all of this said I'm gonna leave it
up to you when I say I'm gonna leave it
up to you I'm gonna say what here's
here's my perspective and then I'm gonna
say that you have you can have your own
perspective I believe that these
allegations are credible I believe the
allegations are credible because this
woman went on the record and because
there are multiple women who
that ROI more reached out to them as
teenagers and that he went as far as
they would allow them to go and then
stopped when they said no right the
allegations seem consistent to me and
they seem credible to me with that said
would I support Rome or the answer is no
but that was not my line for supporting
or I'm or I think the Roy Moore has said
things that would lead me not to support
him anyway now there is a complex
calculus that goes on unfortunately in
politics with regard to the impact of
particular races we are willing to
accept more bad behavior from a
presidential candidate because the
presidency is so important we're willing
to accept bad behavior from Senate
candidates because the Senate is so
important if this guy were running for
dogcatcher would you vote for him the
answer is no if this guy were running
for Congress would you vote for him the
answer is probably no but you have to
decide whether you believe the
allegations are credible and then you
have to take a good hard look inside
yourself and determine whether you think
the allegations are credible but you're
looking the other way because you think
that it is more important to elect
someone who has done bad things but may
implement an agenda that you like if
that's the case then we really have
reached the point where character means
nothing in American politics like
nothing and you're seeing this right
you're seeing this the Alabama state
auditor a guy named Jim Ziegler he
here's what he said quote take the Bible
Zechariah and Elizabeth for instance
Zechariah was extremely old to marry
Elizabeth and they became the parents of
John the Baptist I also take Joseph and
Mary Mary was a teenager and Joseph was
an adult carpenter they became parents
of Jesus okay well first of all I think
it's kind of a miss read from what I
understand about the New Testament the
impression is that it was God
impregnated Mary not not Joseph but in
any case and also I'm not sure where it
says that that Mary was a was a young
teenager when all of this happened says
that she was a Inara
she said she was a young girl but it
doesn't Nara can be a 20 year old in any
case there's there a bunch of people who
rushed to Roy Moore's defense on this
there's a state representative ed Henry
he said if they believe this man is
predatory about the women they're guilty
of allowing him to exist for 40 years I
think someone should prosecute and go
after them you can't be a victim forty
years later in my opinion absolute
nonsense of course he can be a victim
forty years later and then you're seeing
the people who are the most invested in
Moore's victory speaking out on behalf
of Roy Moore so Steven and who is who
tried to take credit for Roy Moore
winning the primaries against against
Luther strange again I don't think
Bannon picked Moore
the bannon's supportive more actually
push more to victory
abandon is is now tied himself to
Moore's leg now he's making the case in
the same way that he made the case with
regard to Donald Trump in the p-word
tape he's now making the case with
regard to Roy Moore that it's the media
that we have to oppose here are the
media report on alleged bad behavior and
we can't say that the bad behavior is
bad we have to hit the media instead and
this does draw a distinction here right
and this is the same distinction I made
a little bit during the campaign and
that is if you vote for Roy Moore while
acknowledging that these allegations are
credible you know I I have doubts about
whether that is good voting logic but I
think that it is possible for you to say
I'm voting for a bad man to stop a
pro-abortion zealot from entering
Congress for example I think that's
possible it's not a logic I hold because
I think the character in our public
servants matters but I think that you
can hold two thoughts at once that
somebody's a bad person and that you
voted for them because the lesser of two
evils right this is sort of the the
Trump argument but what you're seeing
from some people on the right is they're
actually attempting to minimize what
Moore's allegations wore right they're
not they're not actually saying the
allegations aren't true they're saying
even if they are true it's not a big
deal this is a step even beyond voting
for more this is excusing evil behavior
if you believe the allegations are true
here's Steve Bannon basically doing that
but it's interesting the Bezos Amazon
Washington Post that dropped that dime
on Donald Trump is the same Bezos Amazon
Washington Post that dropped a dime to
say afternoon on judge Roy Moore now is
that a coincidence that's what I mean
when I say opposition party right it's
purely part of the apparatus of the
Democratic Party they don't make any
bones about it okay this is quite
disgusting the Washington Post is a
major newspaper they run reports on lots
of people is the Washington Post that
was doing a huge amount of research
actually on Hillary's emails and despite
all the rips on the mainstream media and
I'll get to the mainstream media in just
a second and their hypocrisy but for him
to suggest that it's the Washington Post
just a hit job dismiss the allegations
out of hand
because you don't like the allegations
Steve is too smart for this but Steve is
just manipulative enough for this I know
Steve really well Steve smart and the
him doing the Washington Post Amazon be
so thing is just Steve knows better than
this but Steve is doing it because
obviously Steve wants to be seen as the
head of this Trump estate and therefore
he feels like he has to stand by Roy
more Breitbart is out in full-scale
defense this is not a shock to me I was
there when Breitbart was out in
full-scale defense of Donald Trump's
p-word tape I remember it you were there
you remember it I was there when they
when they threw their own reporter under
the bus after Donald Trump's campaign
manager Corey Lewandowski grabbed her by
the arm hard enough to bruise her then
lied about it publicly I was there for
all of that so it's not it's no surprise
to me the Breitbart has made itself into
an arm of the more campaign and is now
basically doing PR for more on this
story a Joel Pollak who's an editor over
there I know Joel pretty well Joel's on
MSNBC last night again these are not
defenses that these are not defenses
that moral people should be making okay
what Joel's about to say here is not a
defense that a moral person should make
the defense system or should be one
these allegations are not credible and
here's why I think allegations are not
credible right that would be one of they
would be the only real moral defense of
this and then two would be maybe he's
guilty of all of this but it's politics
everybody's dirty I don't like that
defense I think it's gross I don't agree
with it I think that we all should have
basic standards for our public servants
but that would at least be a
intellectually honest argument Joel's
about to make a very intellectually
dishonest argument I think in a moral
argument here the 16 year old and the 18
year old have no business in that story
because those are women of legal age of
consent
that's not my teenagers I mean you can
you can argue that maybe they shouldn't
be writing about teenagers but the point
is it's not inaccurate my point is that
the post has successfully put a
narrative out at least on MSNBC and in
other places that there's this pattern
of teenagers there's really as far as we
know the facts could come out
differently but as far as we know
there's only one relationship that's
been alleged that's problematic
okay I know if you're if you're making
out with 16 year old at 33 that's it
that's a problem that's a problem
Joel has daughters he knows better than
this and if you are if you're if you're
allowing yourself to become the shill of
a campaign to the point where you know
you're saying stuff about a guy in your
own side you would never say about
anyone on the other side again flip the
script for a second if there are
allegations that Bill Clinton had
molested a fourteen-year-old and then
who is he asking me out 16 year olds and
making out with him when he was 33 and
an assistant DA which is what Roy Moore
was at the time what do you think the
right would be doing
here's a little intellectual consistency
not because I want a Democrat to take
the seat in Alabama god forbid I don't
want a Democrat to take the seaton
Alabama my preferred solution here would
be a write-in candidate from somebody to
win that seat which is quite possible
Lisa Murkowski just did it in Alaska
there's no reason you couldn't have a
right in Canada seat for someone who's
not Judge more but one of the things
that I think is is really gross is is
the the capacity it's it's been amazing
to me the capacity the human capacity to
rewrite history and fact in order to
avoid cognitive dissonance is an amazing
thing to me it's an amazing thing to me
you know the fact that there are so many
people who are willing to rewrite in
their own heads the facts of a given
situation so they don't have to feel bad
about what they're doing it's it's to me
one of the the it is to me the number
one problem with human beings just as a
species our biggest problem is that we
are unwilling to live with cognitive
dissonance we are unwilling to live with
the fact that some of the people we may
like politically our bad people or do
bad things and so instead what we end up
doing is throwing all morals under the
bus in order to protect people who we
think are actually doing bad things
again you'll make them the case that a
33 year old making out with a 16 year
old girl is not a problem it's pretty
amazing it's pretty amazing and pretty
disgusting okay so before I go any
further and I want to talk about the
media hypocrisy here too before I go any
further I want to talk a little bit
about our brand-new sponsors over at
filter by comm so one of the things that
you never think about in your house is
the air quality you never think about it
because who thinks about their quality
who thinks about the the the vents who
thinks about the filters that you use on
the vents well you don't think about it
and what you do is you leave those
filters in there for five years and then
you look at them and they are completely
black and they've been filtering out
nothing and it turns out that your house
is full of dust and mold and gross in US
that's why you need to go to filter by
dot-com filter by comm sends you the
size you need within 24 hours plus free
shipping they use double industry
standard emmy RV rating on most filter
sizes and all their filters are
manufactured right here in the united
states they can ship any size into any
quantity and you save 5% when you set up
auto delivery which is great you know
auto delivery is what i would recommend
with filter by comm because it'll just
deliver the new filters to you on a
regular basis and that way you never
have to think about it again it just
comes in the mail you say oh look it
came in the mail that means it's time
for me to replace my filter you replace
the filter and everything is good to go
go to filter
Icom today get the best price on top
quality filters shipped within 24 hours
plus free shipping filter by com
that's filter by dot-com again you never
have to think about air quality again
when it just comes in the mail and you
stick it in the vent and everything is
good to go it's a no-brainer
filter by dot-com best price shipped to
you for free within 24 hours and save 5%
when you get auto delivering filter by
dot-com check it out okay so none of
this is to ignore the hypocrisy of the
left when it comes to these sorts of
sexual assault and sexual harassment
allegations Bernie Sanders for example
he comes 40 says that that Judge more
should step aside I first have to ask
you about this revelation about a man
who could be your colleague in a matter
of weeks whether you think the
Republican Party serves hope that he let
let us hope that he will not be my
colleague or anybody else's colleague
you know I I think you I've heard Chris
that there are a number of Republicans
who are saying that at this particular
time given these horrific charges
against mr. Moore that it would be
appropriate pay him to step aside and
again it's a you know III may not yeah I
just I I may agree with Bernie Sanders
but where was Bernie Sanders on Bill
Clinton was he arguing for him to step
aside and this is the logic that so many
people are using today they're using
this logic I use this logic to turn to
Bob Menendez saying you know it would be
nice if the media presented you know
one-tenth the effort on Bob Menendez
that they will join more now people are
saying well yeah but they've got
reporters at Bob Menendez is hearing
right they've got Politico and CNN is
covered it's true but the New York Times
is a very large newspaper okay there are
a lot of pages in that newspaper is Bob
Menendez on page one or is he on page a
I even cover stuff and still bury it ok
so then so news busters has done a
pretty good study on this and here's
what they found yesterday ok this is the
in the in from nine from September 6th
to Olive 4 to November 10th ok from from
9 6 to 11 10
okay they've covered this here all the
shows and how they have covered Bob
Menendez okay ABC's Good Morning America
again this is over a month of coverage
actually it's um it's almost two minutes
more than two months of coverage in two
months of coverage ABC's Good Morning
America I mentioned it for a combined 1
minute 48 seconds CBS this morning 22
seconds NBC's Today 0 ABC's World News
Tonight 0 CBS this morning
0 NBC Nightly News zero
Roy Moore it is the first 24 hours Good
Morning America 7 minutes CBS this
morning 5 minutes 22 seconds NBC today 4
minutes 22 seconds ABC World News
Tonight
2 minutes 48 seconds CBS this morning 2
minutes 46 seconds NBC Nightly News 2
minutes 38 seconds if you want to know
why everybody is lowering their
standards is because nobody has any
standards if the media were consistent
about this stuff if the media said they
corrupt people should resign then
everybody would be on the same page but
it's very difficult for you to say that
people of the other guy's party should
resign but people of my own party should
remain and that's that's a very
difficult allegation to make again
another one of the people who's been
doing this is Stephen Colbert
you know his Stephen Colbert goes after
as you'll see both Donald Trump and Roy
Moore in this particular clip besides
the 14 year old girl the post talked to
three other women who say more pursued
them when they were between the ages of
16 and 18 and he was in his early 30s my
god these accusations are so damning
voters are either gonna force him off
the ballot or make him president okay
well you know that that's not a Clinton
joke that's a Trump joke obviously
it's a Trump joke now I would just like
to point out Stephen Colbert has had
David Letterman on his show multiple
times David Letterman was apparently
sexually harassing to help over at over
at the Late Show that was the allegation
anyway so any I guess there was a
settlement out of court and all the rest
of it which brings us to Hollywood right
we're gonna get to Hollywood in just a
second where the sexual allegations are
flying fast and furious and yet you're
seeing that this stuff was allowed to go
on Holly wouldn't everybody know about
it for 40 years and nobody did anything
about it I do want to point out one
another area of media hypocrisy and that
is really media malpractice so you know
I've said that I think Sean Hannity's
coverage of President Trump has been
rather sycophantic but that it was very
unfair last night of the entire left
media jumped on Shawn suggesting that
Shawn had defended child molestation
here's chris hayes on MSNBC suggesting
that hannity defended child molestation
or the past month senate republicans
have made it something of an art form
out of ignoring questions about really
Moore's basic fitness for office a man
who was removed twice from the Alabama
Supreme Court for ethical reasons man
who believes that quote homosexual
conduct should be illegal a man and once
that congressman keith Ellison shouldn't
be allowed in Congress because he is
Muslim I anticipated a fake news attack
I anticipated tonight tonight and I wash
and post his fake news what I did not
anticipate was watching a bunch of
conservatives today bend over backwards
to defend molesting a child and yet
somehow that's apparently where we are I
thought I'd lost my capacity for shock
but reading like these are these are
just some of the statements from the
local Alabama officials who were talking
to Daniel Dale today at the Toronto Star
about this behavior it was 40 years ago
I really don't see the relevance of it
she was 32 she was supposedly 14 she's
not saying anything happen other than
they kissed
other than being with an underaged
person he really forced himself I know
it's bad enough but I don't know if he
withdraws it's five weeks the election
that would concede that the Democrat
there is no option to support Doug Jones
the Democratic nominee when you do that
you were supporting the entire Democrat
Party it's like I felt you were talking
about this being profound it's profound
in the sense that there's nothing that
Roy Moore could do that is going to
detach the party from him it appears
okay and then he went directly after
Sean Hannity suggesting that Hannity had
personally defended chat molestation
that is not true here's the actual clip
of Sean Hannity talking about Roy Moore
he did not say is there's a lot of
crosstalk here he did not say that it
was a consensual encounter with a
fourteen-year-old he was talking about
consensual encounters with the 17 or 18
year old it was apparently like 32 and
he dated one girl was 18 one girl was 17
they never said he did there's no sexual
there's kissing involved and then
they're saying this one intentional and
consensual that's true and there's you
know I just ain't Sean it's clearly not
talking about the fourteen-year-old
there so the media jumped on this Media
Matters jumped on this they called for
boycotts of Sean it just demonstrates
how politicized all this stuff has
become we should all be on the same page
about this stuff happening about how
it's bad right and I think that the fact
that we are not demonstrates how much
politics has infused our our lifeblood
and poisoned the well really poisoned
the law okay so I want to talk about
louis c.k and the allegations against
Louie CK but for that you're gonna have
to go over to our website at Daley wire
comm and subscribe $9.99 a month gets
you a subscription to daily wire calm
when you get that subscription get the
rest of my show live you get to be part
of the mailbag
go subscribe right now you can ask me
questions live today I'm sure there'll
be some people who are mad at me today
that's fine I'm happy to answer all
those angry questions so go over to
daily wire comm and subscribe I get the
rest of my show live claiming this show
live Knowles and show live also tune in
next week to watch our next episode of
the conversation it's Tuesday November
14th at 5 p.m. Eastern 2 p.m. Pacific
featuring our very own Michael moles god
help us
Michael's conversation will stream live
on the table by our website Facebook
page YouTube channel it's free for
everyone to watch but only subscribers
can ask the questions subscribe today
ask Michael questions join the
conversation also you get all of these
things plus for a plus you got this the
most wonderful of all beverage vessels
leftist here's hot were called world
famous tumblr you get that for $99 a
year when you get the annual
subscription as well you should to
enrich your life and make it that much
better if you just want to listen for
free later go over to SoundCloud iTunes
YouTube and make sure that you subscribe
leave us a review we always appreciate
it we are the largest fastest-growing
conservative podcast in the nation
[Music]
so speaking of hypocrisy the entire
Hollywood infrastructure that spent
years basically making excuses for
everyone in Hollywood and ignoring it
but when after Donald Trump and is now
going after Roy Moore well they got hit
hard again to let yesterday louis c.k
the allegations are is that movie CK has
a nasty habit of touching himself in
inappropriate ways before unsuspecting
women in 2002 louis c.k who by the way
yeah there's this there's a sort of hot
take online that you can't like louis
ck's comedy now the bad stuff has come
out about him Louie CK is freaking
hilarious okay he's a really good
comedian he's also a garbage human being
apparently okay so both things can be
true at once we had a conversation in
the hallway before the show about
separating the art from the artist about
whether you can still laugh at Bill
Cosby's comedy from 1969 knowing what
Bill Cosby did and I think the answer is
yes you can still laugh at it just don't
give him your money right I think that
you can still watch a Roman Polanski
film we can still watch knife in the
water and sin it's a good movie and
still say the guy who made it's a creep
guy is a rapist right I mean I think
that you can you can do those things you
don't have to like burn every Buffalo
Bills tape you have from the 1980s
because OJ Simpson killed his ex-wife I
just think it's important just as a
society to recognize that because
otherwise we'd start setting up the
societal let this test that are very
weird like you mentioned that you watch
The Cosby Show who you must not care
about date rape
that's silly okay in any case CK
apparently asked two female comedians in
2002 to comes his hotel room and then he
proceeded to get naked and pleasure
himself before them that was not his
only time doing this he did it in 2003
to Abby Schaffner apparently in 2005 to
rebecca quarry and the this story from
the New York Times resulted in the
cancellation of the premiere of his new
movie as well as Stephen Colbert's Late
Night Show appearance apparently in the
new movie there's a scene where Charlie
Day playing one of the characters niblet
mimics publicly pleasuring himself and
in which characters appeared to dismiss
rumors of sexual predation it's this is
really gross stuff and amazingly enough
you're seeing a lot of the Hollywood
elites avoiding talking about it for
sure so you're seeing like Aziz Ansari
apparently was asked directly about he
said I have no comment how you not have
comment how is this tough like
legitimately how is this tough and again
these are allegations let's say that
Luis he can come out and denied them the
women are on the record
talking about them would you deny them
all right let's talk about Kevin Spacey
for just a second okay because the
allegations about Roy Moore and Kevin
Spacey are actually quite similar the
allegation about Kevin Spacey was that
he took a 14 year old to a party and
then brought him in the bedroom and
tried to sexually molest him the
allegation about Roy Moore is that he
picked up a 14 year old and brought her
back to his house and tried to sexually
molest her right those are the
allegations and the allegation is by the
way exactly the same in the sense that
when the 14 year old sent his Spacey
stop apparently spaced he stopped and
when the 14 year old said a Remora stop
Roy Moore apparently stopped now some
people are saying well spacey didn't
deny the allegations more is this is you
know it's true that that is a
significant difference it is also true
that if Kevin Spacey had tonight it
would you believe it would you believe
it if Kevin Spacey had denied it or did
you say
probably happened especially since the
actor was willing to go on the record
again I'm just pointing out here folks
try to be intellectually honest with
yourself that's how you know whether you
are you are acting in accordance with
your morality is if you ask yourself
these tough questions and I'm not
telling you which way you have to come
down and told you how I come down what I
think is the moral thing to do but if
you choose differently that's your
problem it's a free country
but at least be honest about what you're
doing okay time for some of the things I
like things I hate in the mailbag so
things I like there's a movie out by
know about Noah Baumbach who is not my
favorite director I really don't like
his work very much but the mayor what
story's on Netflix which is now getting
all sorts of it's getting rave reviews
and also it's getting buried because
Dustin Hoffman was accused of sexual
harassment and he stars in the movie he
was seen as somebody who would be up for
an Oscar nomination probably for this
the movie itself is not any great shakes
it's nothing where you watch it you're
like I'm blown away by this film but it
is such a wonderfully backhanded
critique of New York liberal culture
that it's pretty spectacular from that
perspective like when you watch it as a
conservative it's sort of conservative
porn it's sort of like you're watching
it and you're realizing that the I don't
know if bomb back meds it this way
probably not but the whole thing is a
brutal critique of New York Upper East
Side Jewish liberalism and it's a very
Jewish movie obviously the mayor what
stories meant to be that way but it's it
really has nothing to do with Jews
because these people you know don't have
anything with Judaism there's just New
York liberals all right here is the
here's a little bit of the preview you
this place is a client that's why we
could get a table so last-minute
that's why they gave us this bigger
table I imagine will sent some
complimentary stuff to $55 for a steak
known for their meat here than $35 for a
salmon get the salmon to blow you for
that price
Harold meyerwitz a son Matthew
yes mrs. Danny also felt my erlik's a
son I didn't realize you have two sons
and a daughter
it would be okay here it'll be nice to
spend time with that no I didn't get a
lot of time with him growing up
they pictures comedy but really isn't a
comedy as much as it is sort of a
dramedy so basically the characters are
you know Ben Stiller is the successful
son who is not artistic so here's a
here's sort of the plot you can pause
the the trailer so the so when when you
actually hear the so here's that here's
the plot basically Dustin Hoffman is an
aging sculptor okay and he's never
created anything that really is
meaningful or great but he's sort of a
minor artist and his sons are Adam
Sandler who is a former pianist who is
unsuccessful and has been basically a
househusband taking care of his kid and
and his other son has been Stiller
they're half-brothers they have merits
the Dustin Hoffman character has been
married three separate four separate
times I guess in the movie an old ones
three divorces and he is and he is a
jerk he's a jerk who sees himself as a
genius he basically ignored Adam Sandler
when Adam Sandler was a kid but he was
very warm to Ben Stiller Ben Stiller
didn't turn out to be artistic but he
went out made a lot of money Adam
Sandler ended up being kind of a
househusband and so the whole movie is
sort of about their relationship with
Dustin Hoffman what's fascinating about
it is that it's meant to I think the
movie is trying to say that art is that
that art is worth it but there is one
key speech that Adam Sandler gives where
he basically says I have to think that
my dad was a genius cuz otherwise he's
just a jackass basically and it does
demonstrate I think in a backhanded way
how the artistic community thinks about
itself it's okay to be a bad person so
long as you create good art I think
embedded in here is one of the messages
that is plaguing Hollywood right now
that Hollywood actually believes that if
you make good art that justifies you
being an awful human being and Dustin
Hoffman sort of gets away with it in the
film being an awful human being but
that's that's sort of the problem and
I'm not sure that I'm not sure Bombeck
meant to say that but if he didn't he
should have because I think it's an
important message okay things I things I
hate so I mean the entire news cycle
would be the thing I hate today
the other thing that I hate is that
Hillary Clinton is trying to claim that
she is now that she and her movement are
now responsible the fever in America has
broken then now Americans are finally
coming back to their senses you know I
think the fever is finally breaking I
think that Americans and as we saw last
night are saying you know what we really
like our health care we don't like
hatred and bigotry and we don't want to
get shot wherever we go and we don't
want to be shot wherever we go I mean I
can't imagine why I can't imagine why we
didn't elect this woman president hey
what a harridan the idea that anyone
wants to be shot wherever they go that's
why we own guns
it's just asinine the idea that everyone
who voted for Trump is a racist it's
just disgusting an asinine the fever is
not going to break because everyone has
a fever okay the reason everyone has a
fever is because our politics have taken
over our morality and Hillary Clinton is
one of the main drivers in that okay
time for the mailbag so Calvin says hey
man I'm a huge fan of yours but I live
in Australia would you ever consider
coming here to speak yeah actually we've
had some invitations from Australia big
travel like that to Australia it always
means that we have to bundle together a
bunch of speeches so we are working on
that we're also working as I say on a
trip to the UK at some point in the
relatively near future menachem says hey
Ben's you believe that aliens and ghosts
exist I think that there's a better shot
that aliens exist and ghosts exist I
don't believe in ghosts in the sense
that I don't think that like a core
period that corporeal beings are
wandering around the hallways of your
house I think that once once your dad
your dad I don't think that you're you
know coming back to talk to people
except maybe in dreams but the idea that
you're like wandering around attempting
to communicate with the with the living
world is not something I buy I think the
spiritual world in the physical world
are somewhat separate the idea that
aliens exist possible I mean there are a
lot of planets out there
would they be intelligent not
necessarily but I think it's it's
implausible to me that there are that
many planets in that many stars and
nowhere has a one-celled organism lived
you know that I find implausible Kathak
says hey man you've held very strong
political opinions since you were young
has having children changed any of your
earlier positions not really because I
think I like the way I was raised I mean
I think that one of the things that when
you have kids what
to change your positions as you tend to
get a little bit stricter on moral
matters but I grew up in an area that
was strict on moral matters and I grew
up in a good situation so I never felt
the need to buck them I think a lot of
people move from sort of libertarianism
toward conservatism when they have kids
I was already conservative socially so
there's no place for me to move Janey
says I'm working on a paper concerning
judicial review
I've always been enticed by your
objections to judicial review I've heard
your rudimentary arguments against it
would like to dive that a lot deeper
into the issue what works are authors do
you recommend besides Waldron if
judicial review were abolished would
there then be a need for written
Constitution there'd be a need for
written constitutions that we would at
least have a document around rich to
rally right you still have to swear your
oath to uphold the Constitution in every
office judicial review would just not
make the judiciary the final repository
of judgment on judicial review that
they're a bunch of books on judicial
review and the problems with it
Bork has talked about it extensively in
tempting of America they're also I'm
trying to remember the name of the
fellow who very very famous book on
judicial review I'll have to look it up
and I'll get back to you I'm sorry Kyle
says when you run for president will you
ask Stephen Crowder to be a running mate
I'll ask Stephen Crown Derby of my
lifting mate he seems like that's that's
more his thing
Cedric says hey bends you also ship the
magnificent left this year's tumblr
abroad to Europe I don't know guys do we
I do not know the answer to that so I'll
have to I'll have to find that out Rowan
says dear Ben the government has to
provide essential services like police
and fire protection yet even with a flat
tax the richest taxpayers still pay much
more in absolute dollars than the
poorest taxpayers in other words the
rich are paying for the poorest police
and fire services why then is it any
different if taxes are used to provide
health care well I mean it's different
because the role of the government is
different if you're asking why a flat
tax is better than a progressive tax
it's because percentages are still
proportionate and the idea of
proportionality is still better than non
proportionality as far as what services
are used these are two separate
questions they did the the veracity of a
flat tax versus what the tax dollars
should be used for are two separate
questions I don't think tax dollars
should be used for health care because
in the end your health care is
individually your responsibility whereas
fire and police protection are in the
end communal responsibilities since fire
can jump home to home and because crime
has as communal effect okay Sarah says
hey Ben you
advertised your ability to better my
life via subscription to the day the
wire alright so I'm an annual subscriber
and a current student UCLA and I cannot
get a spot to listen to you come speak
next week
can I cash it on your offer to better my
life by finding me an extra seat to
attend email me Sara and I will do my
best just and says my sister is 15 years
old she's being influenced by her asked
sjws friends at school and become it
became anti-trump without good reason
other than how he handles himself on
Twitter how do I go about positively
persuading her to conservative ideas and
red pilling her without sounding
condescending well I think that first of
all I think that a lot of what Trump
says on Twitter is really dumb I mean
hope you'd like this has been a thing
that I've been saying for years now I
think that you can uphold conservative
principles without having to defend
everything Trump does and this is a big
mistake I think people make so don't let
that be the hill you die on in other
words don't die on the hill of Trump's
Twitter is great that seems to me a bad
hill to die on politically Brian says hi
then I have heard your opinion on
abortion numerous times in avid listener
my question is what is your opinion on
the morning-after pill I'm truly curious
and appreciate your opinion so my
opinion on the morning-after pill is
that the morning-after pill is abortion
pill again once a human life has been
conceived meaning that it the egg has
been fertilized then you are talking
about the destruction of that incipient
human life and that is a problem to me
Jonathan says dear Ben how do you feel
about labor laws as conservatives one of
our core principles is limited
government do you believe in the
government having labor laws such as a
standard 40-hour workweek thanks no I
don't believe the government ought to be
able to bargain on my behalf against my
employer it is my job to bargain on my
behalf against my employer I am for
private-sector unions that do just this
I'm for private-sector unions that do
just this I am NOT for private or public
sector unions that take advantage of tax
dollars or a legislation that restricts
my rights to contract with someone
freely by the way I do have an answer
from our producers now we do in fact
ship the tumblers overseas so if you are
in Europe feel free to subscribe and get
the tumbler now Mason says one passage
of the Bible that is always interested
me is the story of the Tower of Babel
which obviously comes right after the
story of Noah I've always struggled with
this passage because I don't see what
would be wrong with the people building
a city and a great tower I was wondering
if you could elaborate on the meaning of
this passage sure so I actually was
planning on doing this next week but I
may as well do it now the basic idea of
the Tower of Babel is that as
communitarianism at its worst so the
idea of the Tower of Babel is that
they're not building the tower to better
the lives of the inhabitants they're not
building the tower in order to
anything useful it specifically says
they're building a tower in order to
challenge God in other words the idea is
that we are going to build these massive
edifices to demonstrate the capacity of
humans as a community to build amazing
things and the Midrash you know a lot of
the commentaries on the Torah they talk
about the idea that if a human being the
tower was so great that if a human being
would die in the building of the tower
they would just take the body and stack
it into the tower and then when you
would stop to bury the guy the idea here
is that this is much more like a fascist
regime that it's a fascist regime that
directs all of the communal labor toward
the creation of these massive monuments
not started that's where the betterment
of individuals lives not sort of the
betterment of family situations but
instead a community directed not toward
the betterment of individuals with value
but directed instead at building giant
things in order to demonstrate that
human beings are more powerful than God
that's actually what it says right there
in the Bible ok so this brings us to the
end of this week's mailbag if you want
to be part of next week's mailbag you
need to subscribe it daily wired.com
again $9.99 a month or $99 a year we'll
get you that subscription and we look
forward to seeing you on Monday I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]